My name is Travis Conrad
I gave my entire life to the agency
until they betrayed me
They took my family
They took my future
They wouldn' t even let me die in peace
What's happening to me?
You're gonna die
Again
How long do I have?
You have less than 24 hours to live
Mr. Conrad
finish one last job
and you'll live to see tomorrow
You have no idea what you've done
I'm gonna come at you with everything I've got
Send a strike team to find and kill
Gonna have to get creative
These guys don't play nice
Neither do I
We have nothing to lose
He took my wife
He took my son
So you can either walk away
or I'm gonna walk away over your dead body
Send somebody back for the bodies